tonight I want to dedicate this first
act you're talking about a subject that
I don't think we pay enough attention to
because of the craziness of our world
I'm talking about wildlife now
it's upon us to be stewards of these
creatures who really have no I'm just
kidding we're talking about drum roll
the unpacking
okay funny story
couple weeks ago we were all saying man
Trump just criticized the family of a
fallen soldier what there's no way you
could do anything worse than this he did
Hillary wants to abolish essentially
abolish the Second Amendment but if she
gets to pick her judges nothing you can
do folks
although the Second Amendment people
maybe there is I don't know yep that's
right Donald Trump not so subtly hinting
that gun rights activists should do
something about Hillary Clinton
really you're joking about your
political opponent being whacked okay
guys I used to think rational well
intentioned people could be on opposite
sides of the aisle and intelligent
intelligently debate the merits of both
governing philosophies but you know what
at this point if you vote for Trump
you're just a dick seriously
Sorry Sorry I hope you get destroyed by
a horse sized duck how about that it's
an inside joke I apologize
no because there's no possible way this
can be misinterpreted right okay let's
hear from the Trump's chief spokes
goblin Katrina Pierson and join me as I
watch in amazement as the book pours out
of her man mr. Trump was saying exactly
what he said he was talking about
Hillary Clinton and gun control but
Katrina he was talking about what Second
Amendment activists could do to stop her
if she won well no that's that's
actually not what he was talking about
okay let me stop you right there Hugh
that is what he was talking about I
don't care how convoluted your
explanations we're not stupid we can
hear stop trying to explain him away but
it wasn't just heard trying to
force-feed us this turd taco you're
treating mr. Trump's words like he is
the most articulate person who's ever
graced our ears with his words and and
that is not true
but so let's say that he was an an
English professor with a PhD in grammar
okay
first of all you can't get a PhD in a
subject that's taught in the fifth grade
okay that's like getting a Bachelors of
Science in kickball or something right
and second just to be clear your
argument is that Trump is so incoherent
he can't be held accountable when his
words might constitute a federal crime
and of course what defensive trump would
be complete without the human embodiment
of impotent rage himself Rudy Giuliani
you know how speeches go he was talking
about how they have the power to keep
her out of office the first time that
any of us had any idea that that is the
way it was interpreted is when the
Clinton spin machine interpreted that
way the Clinton spin machine smart-mouth
Clinton spin machine that sounds like a
line bill would have used in the 90s
right hey want to ride the Clinton spin
machine fan I'm guessing
it's where maybe doing those jokes for
the next eight years that's really sad
but once again it's acting like we can't
hear something like he's blaming us for
hearing exactly what Trump said hey
here's what gets me about this okay
Giuliani is he's here diminishing the
power of Trump's words but he's not
always so calm about language we've had
from on top a lot of divisiveness and a
lot of anti police rhetoric there's a
target on police officers backs is
because of groups like black lives
matter that make it seem like old police
are against blacks okay so when Trump
calls for the violent death of his
opposition that's just Clinton spin but
when it's black lives matter they're
literally killing people with the power
of their hypnotizing Negro language look
the difference between a random
protester and someone running to be the
leader of the free world is that once
you're president everything you say has
meaning oh I'll show you how this works
okay look here at the nightly show I
mean I'm the boss right I'm kind of the
president of this show if you will right
you know what I mean okay now look Rory
Albanese is my executive producer oh hey
what's up Larry how's 8:00 great show so
far boss hey thanks all right I
appreciate that
killing it killing it now I might be a
little upset at Rory one day just
talking off the top of my head and I
can't stand Rory sometimes I wish
somebody would just make him go away
now because I'm the boss and I have
influence those words mean
oh wait Colleen leave them alone it was
just words oh oh whoa I'm sorry I your
words are so powerful
thank you
you know I was influenced exactly you
know Holly when you put it that way
actually it's fair what you did is fair
that's the power of my words and I'm on
basic cable I don't care how much they
try to spin this
stop being so careless with your
language all right okay here to explain
himself here to explain himself that's
right is Donald Trump
Thanks
thanks for coming Donna I have to ask
you directly did you or did you not
basically call for the assassination of
Hillary Clinton yesterday well come on
Larry look did I use the word
assassination I mean no I mean come on I
just said there was something people who
believed in you know the good amendment
the one with the guns the Second
Amendment Oh God leave it to a black to
knows everything about guns I mean come
on so unbelievably typical okay I just
said there was something people who
believe in the Second Amendment could do
okay get out to devote write letters or
do it every Lee heavily-armed angry mobs
do okay whatever that is okay it's a big
country no thanks to Obama okay but I'm
supposed to guess where they get a deal
come on let me give me a break I feel
look I feel you know exactly what you
meant and my fear is that they knew
exactly what you meant come on look it
was a joke I mean I get it you don't
know what a joke is believe me i watch
this show it's all good it's a complete
disaster
but I am an entertainer okay so look
I'll actually write a joke right now
watch this it's gonna be hilarious here
we go mmm knock-knock knock-knock
fine who's there who's me don't
interrupt okay I want an answer Donald
did you or did you not basically call
for the assassination of Hillary you
know everything answer that Larry I
really don't okay matter of fact I'm
tired of this political correctness in
America today back in the day a
politician could actually straight-up
shoot a political rifle and I know
because I saw that in black Amal tin
okay
black Hamilton wait first of all just
called animals in all right and that's
your takeaway that we're too politically
correct today we should be shooting
people we disagree with yeah that would
be great right I'm below look but don't
put words in my mouth Larry okay I'm all
joking or I'm improperly implying or say
what they want meaning another it's
called being entertaining okay fine well
when are you gonna stop trying to be
entertaining and start trying to be
presidential when I become president
okay that way whatever I do is gonna be
presidential okay stupid question all
right Donna that'll Chum everyone will
be right
you